Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, die wollen jetzt wegen Corona das böllern verbieten und bei Welt DE sorgt man sich um die geplagte Seele der Deutschen.
Die geplagte Seele der deutschen Tim, eines der unterschätztesten und größten und schwersten Dramen der Menschheitsgeschichte, ja. Die sammeln jetzt in Moria Spenden für die geplagte Seele der Deutschen.
Politik Nummer dreihundertneunundsechzig vom zwanzigsten November zwanzig zwanzig. Das Jahr geht langsam zu Ende Linus.
Ja, Steuererklärung machen.
Behaupten ja immer so ein Jahrzehnt fängt ja erst einundzwanzig also mit der eins an.
Auf mit deinen goldenen Zwanzigern. Ich kann das nicht mehr hören, ey. Geplagte Seele der Deutschen, das ist ein Thema, Tim.
Wenn jetzt bei Twitter schon äh wieder rausgezogen und behauptet wird, was, glaube ich, so nicht belegt ist, das Mad Max zwanzig einundzwanzig äh äh stattfindet. Da muss man ja auch was gegenhalten. Wo bleibt der Optimismus, wenn man ihn braucht, hm?
Ja, wo bleibt der Optimismus? Bei der, in der geplanten Seele des der Deutschen ist wenig Platz für Optimismus, ne. Meine, guck mal, was die mitmachen mussten, dieses Volk, ja. Zwei Weltkriege angezählt und verloren und.
Und dann auch noch Papiermasken tragen.
Jetzt wissen sie, Papiermasken tragen, damit sie keine schweren Lungenkrankheiten kriegen, ja? Und wenn sie sich dagegen wehren, werden sie vom Wasserwerfer auf Stufe eins mit Sprühnebel äh bekämpft, ja.
Unglaublich, was was diesem diesen stolzen Volk zugemutet wird, ja. Unglaublich, ne? Und dann, ne, dann
denken sich die Leute ein Virus aus, das gar nicht gefährlich ist, ja? Und dann wird ein Impfstoff entwickelt und der ist saugefährlich, saugefährlich ist der Tim. Der Impfstoff, der ist so gefährlich, ist der für uns.
Ciao,
Die Deutschen sind ganz schöne Snowflakes, was das betrifft, aber es wird, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen schwierig jetzt von dieser lauten Minderheit mal wieder auf alle äh zu schließen, weil so insgesamt habe ich zumindest äh aus meiner Blase heraus äh den Eindruck,
So eine gewisse Grundkuhl halt ist eigentlich schon da, auch wenn äh Kommentatoren auf konservativen anderes behaupten.
Ich kann ich äh er muss gleich sowas immer an an dieses schöne T-Shirt denken, was äh ich glaube, andere Meister hatte mir ja mal von erzählt. T-Shirt stand,
Deutschland, du Opfer, gib Handy.
Das trifft's ganz gut.
Sind die neue deutsche Opferrolle ist das.
Okay, also ähm äh alles ganz dramatisch. Ähm irgendwie.
Wir wir ähm beklagen ja hier regelmäßig den Verfall der politischen.
Kultur und das politischen des Anstands grundsätzlich ähm so äh haben jetzt die AfD hat jetzt irgendwelche YouTube-Spinner in den Bundestag geschleust und die haben da irgendwie Abgeordnete belästigt
Ähm.
Könnte teuer werden. Ist richtig Straftat und so.
Ja, die dürfen durften ja eh gerade wegen ihrer illegalen Parteispenden erstmal eine halbe Million Strafe zahlen,
hier. Ist ja aber nicht so, als also weißt du, ähm ne, Leute, die sich nicht an Gesetze und Regeln halten, die machen das natürlich auch kalkuliert. Und das äh,
lassen wir das, lassen wir das. Ähm heute äh neue schöne Nachrichten, wo wir sagen können, haben wir haben wir sowieso schon immer gesagt. Insofern ähm.
Würde ich sagen, bring was hinter uns, oder Tim?
Und du weißt, wir können einfach in uns ruhen und es weiterhin toll finden.
Du, wir haben dann einfach, also guck mal, ich meine, die die in dieser Welt bleibt dir am Ende eines, ja? Und das ist wenigstens recht gehabt zu haben. Mehr ja, mehr ist, was willst du hier sonst noch.
Und er hatte doch Recht.
Immer. Er hatte immer recht. Tja, hat er dann auch nichts gebracht am Ende. Ja, so.
Aber wenigstens habe ich das vorher auch schon gesagt, dass ich da nichts von haben werde. Also hatte ich damit wenigstens recht.
Hm
Gut, schauen wir mal, was äh äh im Toetus Hochkatalog heute alles so zu holen ist. Da geht natürlich unser Blick äh in die USA.
Auch ganz schön geplagt. Und ich würde sogar sagen, dir haben auch allen, allen Grund zum Klagen, also.
Ne, na ja, zum Klagen eigentlich nicht, also es stellt sich heraus, dass die ganzen Klagen, die das Trump-Team da jetzt gerade anstrengend abgewatscht werden.
Aber äh ja, also es ist äh um das kurz zusammenzufassen, äh Donald Trump hat die Wahl verloren und hat ja auch schon vorher
ja in Aussicht gestellt, dass er eine solche Niederlage oder dass er eine Niederlage nicht akzeptieren wird und dieser Mann hat auch eine Historie
an, ja
Betrugsvorwürfen, nachdem er irgendwo äh verloren hat, ja, also das war das war ja, glaube ich, sogar noch in der ähm.
In einer dieser mit Clinton auch Hillary Clinton, wo er dann, wo sie, wo sie noch so sagt,
Ey dieser Typ, wenn der irgendwo verliert, sagt der immer, es ist äh betrogen worden. Das hat er bei den Emmys gemacht und da fällt er ihr noch ins Wort und sagt, den hätt den hätte ich gewinnen sollen, den Emmy, den hätte ich gewinnen sollen,
ja und und so macht das natürlich jetzt auch bei der, mit der, mit dem Wahlergebnis, es scheint sich also hab ich ja sowieso schon immer gesagt, es scheint sich jetzt so abzuspielen, dass er,
den Mythos, diese Wahl sei irgendwie nicht mit rechten Dingen abgegangen.
Weiter nähren wird und davon auch nicht mehr Abstand nehmen wird.
Sie erzählen jetzt die ganze Zeit, da hätte es also irgendwie massiven, massiven Wahlbetrug gegeben und ähm,
ich gehe ja auch nicht davon aus, dass er hier diese das Transition Team von beiden da noch reinlassen wird, ne, also üblicherweise hast du halt eine eine äh diese Monate zwischen dem.
Zwischen der tatsächlichen Wahl und der Übernahme der Geschäfte durch den neuen Präsidenten.
Wird eben auch für eine äh ja für eine geordnete Übergabe der des des Arbeitsstandes genutzt,
diese geordnete Übergabe verweigert Trump gerade dem beiden Team. Und ich gehe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht davon aus, dass sich daran etwas ändern wird, weil,
so wie ich das aus, so wie's so ich das einschätze, kannst du dir nicht dazu zwingen,
und also wird er nicht machen. Und ähm das wird für die USA wahrscheinlich.
Problematisch sein. Aber ähm was wir äh natürlich in unserem Bereich der Netzpolitik eben betrachten.
Ist insbesondere, was da jetzt eine Anwältin von Trump sagt über wie denn dieser Wahlbetrug funktioniert,
haben soll und da sind wir genau bei Tims Lieblingsthema.
Den Wahlcomputern.
Ja, weil sie haben ja alles andere haben sie ja jetzt irgendwie durch, ne. Sie haben behauptet, sie hätten nicht beobachten dürfen, stimmt nicht. Sie hätten behauptet, sie könnten da nicht nah genug ran, es wäre hätten Tote gewählt und was nicht alles, haben sie ausgegraben und es wurde halt immer vor Gericht ganz klar widerlegt.
Hast du gedacht hier wir durften die Wahl nicht beobachten. Ja, können sie das beweisen? Ja hier, wir haben Fotos gemacht. Naja, aber sie sind doch da in dem Raum,
ja ähm wer hat denn das Foto gemacht? Ja wir, ja, so waren sie doch da. Und wer ist das dahinten? Ja, das sind unsere Wahlbeobachter. Okay, next, so ist es.
Völlig absurd.
Aber ich meine, das das Ding ist, die Botschaft funktioniert natürlich trotzdem, weil
was tatsächlich in irgendwelchen Gerichtsverhandlungen äh sich abspielt, das interessiert vielleicht ein paar Journalisten und so eine
Teil der Bevölkerung, aber die eigentlichen Adressaten sind ja nicht Leute, die irgendwie an solchen Prozessen wirklich im Detail teilnehmen, sondern die schauen sich halt irgendwelche Reden an und da wird dann irgendwie dieses und jenes behauptet und dann hast du halt so
Fox News, die ja mittlerweile in der amerikanischen Medienlandschaft schon so fast in den in den Bereich von äh.
Halbwegs noch zurechnungsfähig abgleiten grade, ja? Aber dann hast du natürlich auch so totale äh äh wie so O A N.
Weiß gar nicht, wofür das steht, aber das ist irgendwie.
One America News oder so.
Ja irgendwie sowas. Das ist.
Irgendwann mal irgendjemand unwidersprochen in die Nähe von einem kritischen Wort gerückt hat, ist das der neue Haussender von von Trump.
Genau und und das ist wirklich so quasi die Fernsehvariante von wie wie hieß denn noch diese diese äh Zeitschriften mit ihren Ufo-Landungen und so weiter äh.
Gab's auch schon früher irgendwie diese ganzen Verschwörungsplätzchen, diese Dinger, wo die ganze Zeit äh behauptet.
News of the World oder wie hießen die?
Ja und in oder irgendwie sowas, was ich mal ganz genau,
man kann das mal so leicht mit so normalen Boulevardblättern äh verwechseln. Die heißen alle so ähnlich. Aber das ist so im Prinzip so das. Also da da da geht's dann einfach überhaupt nicht mehr um irgendeine Wahrheit, sondern da wird einfach nur noch behauptet und wird einfach nur noch
dargestellt und es ist einfach vollkommen alles überzogen. Und da wird dann halt äh natürlich auch entsprechend eng,
den äh Botschaften sich ausdenkenden Republikanern zusammengearbeitet, egal. Findet auf jeden Fall alles statt.
Und die von dir angesprochene Anwältin.
Ne
Ist da denn jetzt schon wieder?
Also,
die drehen jetzt da richtig durch. So und wenn sie also jetzt überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit mehr haben, irgendwie ähm unwidersprochen was zu behaupten, dann geht man natürlich worauf na na
auf Wahlcomputer, denn, wie wir ja hier schon äh vor der Wahl auch kurz nochmal angedeutet haben, das Problem bei Computern ist
Da kann man nicht überprüfen, ob die richtig gezählt haben oder nicht. Da droht man auf eine Taste oder aufm Bildschirm, also man löst irgendwie ein Stück Software aus und dieses Stück Software schreibt dann in irgendeinen
rein, Tramp ja oder nein? Und wie denn das jetzt gezählt wurde, kann man nicht überprüfen. Lässt sich nicht überprüfen bei einer Geheimwahl.
Ich glaub das muss man vielleicht noch ganz ganz klein anmerken also man kann das schon überprüfen.
Aber dann ist es eben vielleicht nicht mehr verständlich.
Also mit anderen also ne, sonst haben wir nachher die Leute, die sagen, ja hier einmal so verschlüsselt, einmal so signiert, das geht, ja, also klar, du könntest, du kannst theoretisch eine,
ähm digitale äh anonyme, geheime Wahl machen, aber ähm,
diese deren Integrität im Zustandekommen kannst du nicht mehr gegenüber leihen, beweisen. Und das war genau dieses Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, die wesentlichen Schritte von,
Vorgang und Auswertung müssen.
Jedermann nachvollzogen werden können und genau das ist halt vollkommen unmöglich mit Computern. Und äh,
die Computer, die da in den USA zum Einsatz kommen, das sieht man ja äh regelmäßig auf diesen Hacker äh Kongressen. Ja, also die, die, die, die überleben sicherheitstechnisch äh nicht, wenn du drei Minuten mal das Fenster aufmachst. Also da sind die ja schon komplett umgefallen
und das ist jetzt so sozusagen das Argument von ihr. Sie meinte so, ja, sieben Millionen Stimmen, ja,
Lustigerweise hätte das äh genau zufällig gereicht, um jetzt irgendwie Trump ein Sieg zu bescheren. Also genau genommen, hätten sogar nur drei oder vier gereicht, aber egal. Äh,
Das wäre jetzt halt alles irgendwie so gewesen und dann wird dann halt links und rechts gezeigt, auf irgendwelche Unternehmen
an irgendwas beteiligt äh äh sind, wo dann natürlich dann gleich wieder das äh George Soros und andere übliche Targets äh herangezogen werden. Da wird dann einfach mal behauptet.
Schweine. Die Kommunisten Schweine sind das.
Kommunisten, die jut, was halt so üblicherweise immer wieder herausgezogen wird. So und das steht dann im Raum und das Problem ist, man kann das halt nicht widerlegen. Also man kann behaupten, dass es nicht stimmt, aber man kann's nicht beweisen.
Ich glaube zwar nicht, dass das groß was ändern wird, aber äh es wird halt diese Stimmung weiter aufgeheizt lassen bis zum bitteren Ende.
Und es es ist halt schockierend, weil das so, weil das halt von vorne herein klar war, ne. Also ähm was die da machen und dass das finde ich ja so das.
Das war die Strategie. Ich meine, der hat von Anfang an gesagt,
Wir brauchen ein Ergebnis an am Tag der Wahl. Der hat am Anfang von Anfang an seine Wähler für dorthin gehen mobilisiert und.
Ähm dann eben quasi ne dieses sich nach und nach verschieben, dadurch dass die vernünftigen Leute Briefwahl gemacht haben und die Vollidioten heizt sich da in diese Schlangen gestellt haben ähm darauf hat er komplett abgezielt,
und jetzt äh unterstellen sie halt jetzt hier irgendwie diese diese auch noch in der in der in der Wahl-Software,
und in den Wahlcomputern schwachstellen. Und das das katastrophale daran ist, ja diese Dinger sind ja unsicher wie nur was,
Sind sie ja tatsächlich. Ähm bei dem Voting Village auf der Defcon geht es immer nur noch darum, wie schnell man alle dort aufgestellten Votinge hackt. Nicht.
Ja, das ist nur noch eine, also es geht Preise werden nur nach Zeit vergeben, nicht nach F überhaupt Erfolg. Das ist so ähm also dass dass die gehackt werden, steht gar nicht mehr zur Debatte.
Und um das gleich nochmal klarzustellen.
Dass sie theoretisch hackbar sind, ist nur so ein Randaspekt. Das Hauptproblem bei solchen Dingern ist immer, du musst nur die Softwareverteilungsstruktur,
die eigentliche Kontrolle über diese Maschinen in irgendeiner Form äh unter deine Fittiche bekommen,
und dann ist schon getan. Also es ist sehr viel mehr ein Problem von innen als von außen. Auch wenn das natürlich auch möglich ist.
Und ähm ja, also da können wir uns jetzt genau diese.
Dinge eben anschauen, wo man eben sieht, aha, guck mal, ne? Deswegen haben wir davor immer gewarnt und jetzt kann man sich in den USA anschauen, so sieht das aus,
Wenn jemand diese offensichtliche Schwachstelle auch da mal wirklich rücksichtslos und bösartig ausnutzt. Wahnsinn.
Womit wir schon beim Thema Schwachstellen bleiben könnten, denn äh ja, kann ich ein bisschen aus meiner beruflichen.
Erfahrung sprechen wenn man Systeme baut macht man sich natürlich auch darüber Gedanken.
Wie die sich eventuell verhalten, wenn da bestimmte Schwachstellen drin sind.
Und man kann jetzt quasi, ne, ein System so bauen, dass es ja, sagen wir mal, hoch riskant ist, ja? Ähm und bestimmte Schwachstellen, ja, ganz katastrophale Folgen hätten.
Oder man kann eben versuchen, die Systeme so zu bauen, dass das ihnen.
In Rente Risiko geringer ist und der schnellste Weg ähm dahin, dass einer Maschine inherrente Risiko zu verringern, ist natürlich einfach die dort gespeicherten oder dort verarbeitet Daten zu minimieren
zu verschlüsseln oder sonstiges, ne? Also
beispielsweise, wir haben ja hier in der letzten Sendung über Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt und gesprochen, haben gesagt, zu Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung ist eben eine Möglichkeit der starken Abminderung
Risikos auf dem ähm Kommunikationsserver.
Und ähm Anfang des Jahres gab es in Deutschland ja eine Debatte über eine zentrale oder eine dezentrale ähm Corona App.
Und ähm da waren,
wir ja starke Komponenten des dezentralen Ansatzes, weil dieser aufgrund seiner Datensparsamkeit eben einen Datensatz dann am Ende zur Verfügung hat oder benutzt, der nicht ähm.
Dem einfach kein Risiko mehr, kein nennenswertes Risiko mehr inhalent ist, spezifisch dadurch, dass ja die Daten, die man jetzt zum Beispiel bei der Corona-Warn-App an den Verifikationsserver sendet, sowieso nachher veröffentlicht werden. Das heißt,
ja? Dieses System ist von sich aus sehr viel unkritischer als ein,
Dezentrales System. So und was stellt sich raus.
Es gab in dem Server der deutschen Corona-Warn-App eine Sicherheitslücke.
Diese Sicherheitslücke wurde jetzt geschlossen. Sie war im Backend und ermöglichte eine Remote Code Execution. Das also Remote Code Execution ist so quasi das Schlimmste, was es ähm,
was es quasi an Schwachstellen für ein System geben kann, ähm nämlich, dass du.
Das System irgendwie dazu bringst, dich Abitäre, Kommandos ausführen zu lassen, ja? Ähm klassisches Beispiel.
Ist halt irgendwie, ne, das Input, was du gibst, wird irgendwo an ein Terminal Kommando gegeben und dein Input äh
kannst du halt irgendwie abschließen mit einem Semikolon und einem beliebigen weiteren Befehl dahinter schreiben. Das heißt,
du bist also jetzt in der Lage, diesen Computer zu bedienen, als säßt du selber dran? Gibt's noch natürlich die Abstufung, ähm läufst du dann mit Rutrechten ähm oder läufst du mit eingeschränkten
Rechten des Servers, den du gerade explodierst, aber sie hatten auf jeden Fall ähm.
In ihrem Java-Code, wenn ich das jetzt richtig hier in dem Artikel lese, eine Schwachstelle, die eine ähm,
Remote Code Execution ermöglicht. Und das Spannende ist, die äh diese Schwachstelle wurde gefunden durch das Gitthub Security Lab
Die haben quasi nach Mustern für bestimmte Klassen von äh Wachs gesucht und.
Dann lassen die quasi auf Githup durch die Repositors automatisch scannen. Kriegst du auch teilweise, wenn du irgendwelche irgendein alte äh Repositor hast oder so, eine Meldung und sagen dir, die, guck mal, da ist eine Schwachstelle drin, ne, da ähm oder du hast
hier auf eine alte Library und die hat eine Schwachstelle. Also die helfen dir so ein bisschen und scannen das und die haben tatsächlich in dem Code äh für die für die
Corona-Warn-App-Server eine Schwachstelle gefunden.
Und hier steht nur etwas kryptisch die Ausgabe einer Fehlermeldung wurde als Code interpretiert. Man kann sich jetzt im Zweifelsfall in dem Gittrepositori anschauen, wo da in den letzten Tagen was geändert wurde. Dann sieht man auch die Schwachstelle. Ähm.
Und äh ja wurde halt von der äh wurde halt von Deutsche Telekom mit SAP gefixt. So, warum erzähle ich das jetzt so? Das Spannende daran ist.
Dass ähm dieser Server quasi, ne, das Risiko,
mit dieser Reboard Code Execution. Das Schlimmste, was ein Angreifer da hätte machen können, wäre jetzt vielleicht massenhaft irgendwelche falschen Codes da einspeisen,
oder die Codes, die auf dem Server sind, löschen. Aber es wäre eben.
Kein weiterer es es bestand kein weiteres Risiko für die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer. Insbesondere nicht für für jetzt irgendwie jemanden der diese App auf dem ähm Smartphone installiert hat. Und genau das ist der Grund,
warum wir damals für dieses,
dezentrale System geworben haben, damit genau dieses Risiko nicht ist. Die gleiche Schwachstelle in einem zentralen System wäre,
ein Desaster gewesen und so kann ich dazu eigentlich nur sagen, erstens haben wir sowieso schon immer gesagt und zweitens wurde jetzt eben dank des dezentralen Systems,
Die geplagte Seele der Deutschen etwas weniger geplagt und das doch gut.
Wird sie natürlich nicht honorieren, aber ist trotzdem so. Beginn, ja, es wir gehen im Schongang an die Gesellschaft heran.
Ist doch schön, wenn die deutsche Seele mal ein bisschen weniger geplagt.
Weichgespült wird.
Sowas kommt von sowas und genau deswegen, genau deswegen ist es nicht schlimm und da oder ist es jetzt nicht tragisch, dass es diese Schwachstelle gab, weil eben sie, obwohl es eine hochkritische Schwachstelle ist,
das System so gebaut war, dass der,
potentielle Schaden, den eine Angreiferin damit hätte ähm anrichten können. Ähm sage ich mal, ich nehme ich stelle mir jetzt mal vor, was das Schlimmste gewesen wäre, wäre wahrscheinlich, dass du ähm,
irgendeine Form von äh Intimitätsproblemen auf dem Server hast, der entweder zu viel oder zu wenig warnt, weil der Angreifer, weil die Angreifer irgendetwas löschen oder manipulieren
aber ähm
dadurch, dass du ja Audid lockst dafür hast, könntest du den dann in dem Moment, wo du der Angriff festgestellt hast, im Zweifelsfall wiederherstellen und wieder in in den,
integeren Zustand bringen. Und das wär's dann gewesen. Kleinere Störungen im Betriebsablauf, aber kein Privacity-Desaster.
Macht man's richtig, funktioniert's auch schon. Nicht ganz so äh.
Prozesse im Griff, hat unser äh Gesundheitsminister, könnte man behaupten, kann man vielleicht auch anders sehen, wie ihr vielleicht mitbekommen habt, hat äh sich der Gesundheitsminister eine Corona-Virusinfektion äh
eingeholt,
Wie könnte das passiert sein? Wissen wir nicht, wird er schon irgendwo äh herbekommen haben, was etwas delikat ist? Also er hat wohl am,
war das am zwanzigsten, zweiundzwanzigsten irgendwie so in diesem Zeitraum.
Wurde das bekannt, dass er positiv getestet wurde, also Oktober und.
Er war ein, zwei Tage vorher, also am achtzehnten Oktober in einem Restaurant äh in Berlin,
namens Ponte und hat sich dort mit ein paar Leuten getroffen plus Personenschützer, was man halt so dabei hat als äh Minister in Deutschland,
und natürlich äh nachdem er positiv getestet wurde, hat er beim Gesundheitsamt sich äh gemeldet, wäre jetzt auch noch schöner und hat äh angeblich da so eine vierseitige Liste von Kontakten,
abgegeben, die er denn nun in dem fraglichen Zeitraum von ein, zwei Wochen gehabt äh hatte und ja und damit war dann die Sache,
Das Problem ist nur, dass eine Frau, die am Nachbartisch saß.
Siebenundsiebzig Jahre alt, auch sich eine Coronavirusinfektion äh eingefangen hat,
Und generell mit dem Zustand in diesem Restaurant an dem Abend wohl nicht so glücklich war. Nicht weil der Spahn da war, sondern weil schon die äh Kellner und Besitzer mit so,
Plastikvisieren, rumlaufen, diese bitte endlich mal verbieten. Ich meine, es war ja.
Wirklich nur für die ganz Dummen, ne.
Schön gedacht am Anfang, aber ich habe das auch schon im Supermarkt gesehen und muss sagen, echt äh bin kurz davor, auszurasten,
Leuten erlaubt hat, also vor allem noch diese kleinen Mini-Plastikvisiere, weißt du?
Du hältst diese Sprungchancen.
Diese Sprungchanzen zum Hochspucken, zum Gülle verteilen.
Und äh ich meine, da sind wir jetzt irgendwie, glaube ich, schon weit genug, dass das einfach mal nichts bringt. Also nichts gegen einen, ein Visier als zusätzlicher Schutz.
Ja, das ist nämlich im Wesentlichen ein Eigenschutz,
Ein Eigenschutz insofern, als das ja zum Beispiel auch eine Infektion über die Augen theoretisch äh möglich ist und da ist natürlich so ein Tröpfcheninfektionen speziell problematisch, weil wenn ich immer da anquatscht,
Ne, kann es natürlich sein, dass so kleine Tropfen halt auch direkt in die Augen kommen. Da ist es vielleicht durchaus sinnvoll, sowas noch zu haben oder eine Brille zu tragen, was auch immer.
Aber es nützt natürlich null gegen Aerosole und mittlerweile ist, glaube ich, klar, dass das das Hauptproblem ist. Also Masken tragen, Masken tragen, Masken tragen. Haben sie hier nicht gemacht und äh warum bringen wir das jetzt überhaupt auf? Na ja, weil,
Der Spahn äh offenbar diesem Restaurant auch nicht Bescheid gesagt hat. Das hat nämlich dann immer erst diese Siebenundsiebzigjährige gemacht,
Die haben äh natürlich im Prinzip schon indirekt über die Medien darüber äh was mitbekommen, aber ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie sich da äh gemeldet hätten.
Gute Frage.
Ist eine Frage der der richtigen Prozesse, ne? Ich meine gut, als Gesundheitsminister hat man noch was anderes zu tun und wenn er da irgendwie äh vielseitiges Kontaktformular beim Gesundheitsamt äh abgibt, dann,
ne, ist man natürlich jetzt erstmal rein rechtlich aus dem Schneider. Nur das Problem ist.
Das kommt halt irgendwie nicht so geil, wenn man sich darauf verlässt, weil das Gesundheitsamt hat, halt in diesem Restaurant nie angerufen. Und sonst hätten sie's halt auch überhaupt nicht mitbekommen.
Sag mal, hat jetzt eigentlich diese siebenundsiebzig Jahre alte Frau sich beim Gesundheitsminister angesteckt? Er war auch irgendwie so.
Wissen wir nicht.
Ist auch so der hat dich denn infiziert? Er hat ja Gesundheitsminister, es hat auch wirklich peinlich, ne?
Ich meine, das wissen wir nicht. Das kann auch genauso gut andersrum gelaufen sein, ja.
Also äh das will ich jetzt überhaupt nicht. Ähm äh ich will da nichts unterstellen, weil das dazu würde es noch nicht mal ausgereicht haben, dabei gewesen zu sein.
Also ich denke, man muss aber man muss ja mal ganz klar sagen, was also was wieder die der Ablauf des äh Infektionsgeschehens bei diesem italienischen Restaurant.
Geschildert wird, ne? Mitte Oktober.
Innenraum eines schlecht belüfteten Restaurants, ja? Kellner ohne Maske, ja und das, das ist derjenige,
der hier der geplagten Seele der Deutschen äh über seine Infektionsschutzgesetze diese äh Regeln äh,
maßgeblich ähm,
aufdrängt, ja? Und wenn der sich dann aufführt, wie hier so ein äh Ken FM oder soweit, beim äh dann äh macht das keinen guten Eindruck.
Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
Wenn ihr dann nochmal das Restaurant nicht informiert oder so, jetzt behauptet er natürlich Hatter, Gesundheitsamt ist schuld. Ja geil, da würde ich mich auch freuen als Gesundheitsamt, wenn du dann wenn dann auch noch so ein so ein ähm.
Wenn der Gesundheitsminister dir dann auch nochmal direkt bei der ersten Gelegenheit in in dich Backstep, weil also das ist alles wirklich, das macht alles keinen guten, keinen guten, einen.
Ja, vor allem am achtzehnten Oktober in einem Restaurant innen? Echt, also da habe ich mich schon längst wieder komplett weggeschlossen. Ich war.
Das hätte man als also als Gesundheitsminister ist das äh zieht sich das nicht, ne? Äh und was ich ähm.
Was das ja sehr klar zeigt, ne. Ich meine, wir,
Ich habe da ja jetzt mich öfter hier schon zu zu geäußert und habe da auch nochmal diese Artikel dazu geschrieben, ne, in denen ich sage, was wir eigentlich brauchen, ist halt eine Cluster-Erkennung,
in der Corona-App
ja? Und da hier zeigt sich ja genau die Grenzen des Zettelsystems und dieser ganzen Herangehensweisen, die ich immer kritisiere, dass du nämlich äh
eben keine Garantie hast, dass das Restaurant vernünftig informiert wird oder überhaupt vernünftig informiert werden kann. Wenn man hier mit so wie ich es,
ähm vorgeschlagen habe oder wie's, Entschuldigung, wie es natürlich die Autorin von vorgeschlagen haben, wie ich es nur gut finde. Ähm
da hätte der Spanier jetzt rucki zucki, ne, in Windeseile über seine über seine mehrere Millionen teure App ähm,
dieses Restaurant informieren können. Ne, also er demonstriert hier mit diesem Fall, der ihn betrifft, sehr.
Klar, warum er genau das machen sollte, was äh was ich ihm empfehle.
Tja, macht er aber nicht.
So ist es. Nee, also es ist schon wirklich ein bisschen peinlich. Ausgerechnet der Gesundheitsminister.
Naja, ähm.
Unsere Innenminister sind ähm auch unbelehrbar und zwar haben wir jetzt ähm drei Bundesländer, die sich ähm.
Die dazu drängen.
Man möge eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung aufnehmen und da fragst du dich auch so ein bisschen, also die drei die drei Innenminister kommen aus Hessen, Niedersachsen und NRW.
Und jetzt muss man natürlich mal direkt sagen, ach Entschuldigung, Justizministerin, tschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung. Ähm.
Muss man natürlich mal sagen,
Also das mit der Fortdatenspeicherung ist ja echt ein relativ altes Thema. Das wurde abgeurteilt vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, das wurde abgeurteilt
ähm vom EUGH und ähm diese Richtlinien wurden überall als
Ja, also sowohl auf der europäischen äh auf der nationalen Ebene, als auch auf der europäischen Ebene. Als verfassungswidrig,
abgeurteilt, ja? Und die Diskussionen darüber sind ähm.
Wie alt ist jetzt die Ford Staatenspeicherungsdiskussion? Ich würde jetzt so schätzen, bald zehn Jahre, oder? War das so zwanzig zehn.
Bestimmt.
Als sie das erste Mal hochging oder war das sogar schon zwanzig neun oder so.
Guck mal, wann die sich der Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatenspeicherung gegründet hat. Das dürfte, glaube ich, das ganz gut äh wiedergeben.
Also zwanzig sechzehn hat sie der EUGH.
Zweitausendfünf.
Zweitausendfünf ging das los, ne? Also eine fünfzehn Jahre alte Debatte.
Die in Deutschland mit Deutschland liegt das seit zwanzig siebzehn auf Eis, zwanzig sechzehn hatte der EuGH festgestellt, dass das Grundrechtswidrig ist. In äh Deutschland haben eben mehrere Gerichte das für rechtswidrig erklärt. Es gibt nochmal gesonderte Verfahren gerade vor dem EuGH gegen die konkreten deutschen Regelungen
ja? Und in dieser Situation ähm kommen also jetzt diese drei Justizminister und Justizministerin und.
Fordern, ähm die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wieder,
Und es ist sehr schön, was sie da für eine äh Pressemitteilung veröffentlicht haben, was insbesondere eine traumhafte Äußerung gibt von Eva,
Kühne Hörmann.
Eva Kühne-Hörmann ist die Justizministerin von Hessen und sie gehört, wie man an den Äußerungen auch sehr gut versteht, äh sofort erkennt der CDU an, äh sagt zum Beispiel,
ähm ein Satz äh wieso,
die Bekämpfung von schweren Straftaten im Internet gehört zu den vordringlichsten Aufgaben unserer Zeit, unsere im Illa haben häufig große Schwierigkeiten, die Täter zu ermitteln, wenn diese im Internet keine Informationen von sich preisgeben.
In diesen Fällen ist der digitale Fußabdruck,
häufig der einzige Anhaltspunkt, den wir haben, an den wir aber nach der nach derzeitiger Rechtslage nicht herankommen. Es ist völlig unbefriedigend.
Ohne die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausschließlich die Täter geschützt werden und nicht die Opfer und ferner sagt sie dann, sie fordere,
eine Versachlichung der Debatte, ja? Und das da habe ich dann so ein bisschen über diese Formulierung Versachlichung der Debatte philosophiert und da ist mir eigentlich aufgefallen, dass eine Versachlichung der Debatte noch nie,
einer Person gefordert wurde, die eine sachlichen Beitrag zur Debatte geliefert hat, ja? Eine Versachlichung der Debatte.
Fordern immer nur diejenigen, die,
die Unsachlichkeit der Debatte sehr stark vorantreiben und und auch zum Ziel haben. Und äh da habe ich äh meinen meinen Gedanken auf Twitter geteilt und er wurde mir von Kai Biermann vielen sicherlich bekannt, ähm investigativ ähm,
bald Zeit und äh oder Zeit Online und auch ähm Autor beim Neusprechblog. Der hat mich da auf ein.
Beitrag von zweitausendelf im Neusprechblog hingewiesen, den äh Martin Hase, Maha, auch aus dem CCC bekannt äh geschrieben hat, Versachlichung,
Politikvariante des im Sandkasten heulend gebrüllten. Ich will das nicht mehr hören, ihr seid gemein
Wenn alle Argumente gegen einen Diskutanten sind, bildet die Forderung nach Versachlichung das letzte Mittel, denn sie enthält den indirekten Vorwurf,
alle anderen hätten nicht etwa Recht, sondern seien lediglich lediglich,
unsachlich und wenn jemand die Versachlichung einer politischen Debatte fordert ist die Debatte beendet und der Forderer der argumentative Verlierer. Finde ich sehr schön.
Erweiterung von Gottwinds Gesetz sehr schön.
Wobei das ist, äh genau, das ist in Anlehnung an äh Richard sechsten und sie haben auch ja, also genau je länger eine politische Diskussion dauert, desto höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand die Versachlichung derselben fordert, ist die Biermann-Hase-Erweiterung von Gottwins Gesetz
Ja, ähm was willst du dazu jetzt noch sagen, ne? Ich meine, wir haben hier im im Logbuch regelmäßig die ähm Erfolge.
Die die Strafverfolgungsbehörden sammeln und äh äh erzielen,
Ich finde es sehr schön, sie nennen's erstmal jetzt hier, ne, sie versuchen die Begriffe zu ändern, sie wollen von Vorratsdatenspeicherung weg zu Verkehrsdatenspeicherung.
Und sie nutzen äh hier den digitalen Fußabdruck, ja? Was ich sehr schön finde,
das das Ding ist natürlich auch hier eine schöne Verzauberung, also Fußabdruck soll natürlich so ein bisschen weg von der soll, das soll anonymer klingen, ne,
Das ist so mit dem Fußabdruck, den der Täter am Tatort hinterlassen hat. Ja, natürlich, ne? Den Schuh haben ja viele, aber das Reifenprofil und Schimansky äh,
hält jetzt hier ein Bleistift auf dem Boden und mit ein bisschen Reifenprofil und findet dann an deinem Golf eins wieder oder so totaler Unsinn, ne? Ähm.
Worum es bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ja geht und auch der Begriff Verkehrsdatenspeicherung sagt das ja auch, dass eben der gesamte Internetverkehr aufbewahrt wird und zwar nicht nur am Tatort, ja, sondern,
alles, was alles, was alle gemacht haben, ja, also du hast mit anderen Worten von allen Menschen, jeden einzelnen Schritt,
deiner Fußabdrucke, mit deinen Fußabdrücken erfasst, um dann irgendwann einmal in diesen Daten zu wühlen, ähm wenn dir irgendetwas,
wenn du da irgendeine Straftat verfolgen möchtest.
Das ist nämlich überhaupt interessant in in dieser Debatte wird ja dann auch immer gerne,
Immer so der Spin, das ist doch es gab doch schon mal einen einen äh zweiten Vorschlag, wie man das dann jetzt angeblich nennen sollte. Kannst dich da noch dran erinnern? Ich mir fällt es gerade nicht ein.
Oder.
Nee, nee, es gab äh anstatt Vorratsdaten, also sie versuchen auf jeden Fall immer wegzukommen von diesem Begriff, weil er natürlich an sich schon verbrannt ist, aber natürlich auch weil er im Gegensatz zu so was wie Verkehrsdatenspeicherung, ja, der letzten Endes nur sagt, na ja, da gibt's irgendwo.
Zum Mindestspeicherpflicht war das.
Mindestspeicherpflicht, genau, ne? Sie wollen weg von diesem Vorrat,
weil das ist eigentlich das Wort, was es eben sehr gut ausdrückt, worum's hier geht. Hier werden Daten auf Vorrat gespeichert. Hier werden die Daten erstmal gespeichert, bevor irgendwas passiert ist.
Und genau dieser Datenpool ist das Problem. Wir hatten ja auch vorhin, ne, hier äh der CBA-Server ist jetzt irgendwie gehackt, aber der hat halt nicht auf Vorrat irgendwelche Daten gespeichert, indem man dann hätte äh herumwühlen können
und genau deswegen möchten sie natürlich auch immer wieder auf andere Worte kommen, aber ich glaube, es wird ihnen nicht so ohne weiteres gelingen.
Ich würde, ich würde das, äh ich würde das ja ganz anders ziehen mit den Eupeln, muss man, ne? Ich würde erstmal für meine Kampagne, man bräuchte einen lustigen, lustiges Maskottchen. Zum Beispiel Puschi. Äh ist der Verkehrshamster.
Der Hamster. Puschi der Verkehrshamster. Der der Hamster, der Hamster, deine Verkehrsdaten.
Ganz dicke aber süßer ist er als kleine der ne? Und da kannst du halt gucken und und manchmal hilft der Puschi dabei den äh dem Missetäter zu fangen im Internet. Das ist doch schön oder nicht?
Ja
Können wir bestimmt einen schönen schönen malen, so einen und dann kommt der Datenelch und auf jedem Datenech ist auch so ein kleiner Verkehrsamt.
Er kann ja noch so eine kleine Kommissarmütze aufhaben.
Ist sie? Dete Detektiv, so eine Detektivlupe. So, so würde ich das machen.
Oh Gott. Ja, schön in Karo, alles natürlich. Oh.
Ja, ist äh das ist auch wirklich irgendwie so ein Zombie und äh ja, also sie kommen dann natürlich wieder, also das ist ja, das ist ja das Spannende, dass sie ähm.
Muss man ist ja wirklich auch so absurd. Also ähm was ja übrigens beim beim äh Staatstrojaner genauso immer ist, die kommen dann mit nicht gelösten.
Äh Strafverfolgungsverfahren oder auch nur ordnungs äh Widrigkeiten, ja und sagen, das konnten wir nicht aufklären,
Weil wir eben nicht wussten, wer der Täter ist, ne? Und dann sagen sie aber, ja und wenn wir aber einen Staatstrojaner gehabt hätten, dann hätten wir das aufklären können. Oder wenn wir aber hier einen ähm.
Eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehabt hätten, dann hätten wir das aufklären können. Was aber natürlich eine ein äh Schluss ist, der in der Form nicht ohne weiteres ähm zulässig ist,
wir haben,
Ermittlungsverfahren ist gescheitert, weil also zum Beispiel mit eurer Vorratsdatenspeicherung werdet ihr mich nicht kriegen, weil meine Vorratsdaten sicherlich nicht auf deutschen,
Servern anfallen, ja? So als kleines Beispiel. Aber trotzdem wird natürlich,
Also, ne, es wird äh es wird quasi eine Maßnahme gefordert, deren Effizienz oder Effektivität.
In Frage steht und jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, ja, wenn man die Maßnahme nicht ausprobiert, kann man's ja auch nicht wissen, ob sie hilft. Doch, wenn man sich aber anschaut, was in den Ländern los war, die diese Maßnahme ergriffen haben, dann sieht man, dass dort die,
Aufklärungs- und Strafverfolgungsquoten sich nicht geändert haben, ja? Also dass diese Maßnahme eben nicht geeignet ist, das Problem zu lösen,
für das das zu lösen sie gefordert wird. Und diese Evidenzfeindliche Politik,
Finde ich ganz schlimm. Und da könnten sich mal hier diese ganzen äh Maskendetektive äh mal mit auseinandersetzen. Die wollen ja immer, dass alles gut,
begründet ist und mit Studien belegt, ja? Aber da könnten sich mal wirklich mit auseinandersetzen und sagen, hier,
den Erfolg der Verkehrsdatenspeicherung, den gibt's gar nicht. Ja, da ersetzen ja einfach Verkehrsdatenspeicher äh Corona durch Verkehrsdatenspeicherung und plötzlich können die mit den gleichen Sätzen Dinge sagen, die auf einmal sinnvoll sind.
Na ja.
Kommen wir zu den Etwas besser, besseren Nachrichten.
Etwas. Wir berichteten ja darüber, dass YouTube DE das kleine, praktische Tool zum Archivieren von
Inhalten im Internet, also primär Video- und Audioinhalten, Mediendateien
auf Plattformen rumgammeln und die ähm ein bisschen unpraktisch zu benutzen sind, wenn sie da so äh sind
äh dass dieses Tool von Gitterp entfernt wurde, also das entsprechende äh Developer Rhyposito, also der Ort, wo quasi der Code liegt und wo äh gemeinsam mit anderen Entwicklern dran gearbeitet werden kann.
Da es ja eine DMC äh DCMAsierte äh Klage der
Ria gegeben hat, also dieser Rekord Rekordindustrie, Socialation of America. Ja, also die.
DMCA ist der Digital Millennium Copyright Act.
Digital DMCA oder DCMA, DM.
Digital Millennium Copyright.
DMCA Notizen stand hier DCMA und ich wunderte mich gerade selber. Ähm.
Genau. So, mit der Begründung, dass dieses Tool ja dazu in der Lage wäre, irgendwelche ähm Schutzmaßnahmen zu hintergehen.
Und wir hatten das, glaube ich, ja auch letztes Mal schon dargelegt, dass dem halt eigentlich mitnichten so ist. Dieser Geist, der äh sich in diesem Gesetz wiederfindet, war so im Wesentlichen die Zeit, wo.
So auf dieser Zeit, wo,
DVDs rauskam, man versucht hat äh die zu kopieren, dann wurde da halt ein entsprechender Krypto Algorithmus äh draufgepackt in dieses System und äh alle versuchen das eben zu knacken
sollten dann einfach verboten werden. Hat natürlich auch nicht viel genutzt, aber,
Gesetzgebung ist da und wird halt heutzutage immer erweitert und wird eben benutzt, um alles mögliche runterzunehmen. Gitta hat dann erstmal pariert und hat das eben runtergenommen und dann war natürlich die Aufregung groß
weil es kommt irgendwie nicht so geil
Wenn du jetzt so die Plattform für alle Nerds auf dieser Welt bist und dann wird so eins der beliebtesten Nerd-Tools einfach mal so grundlos weggeklagt.
Das äh gab dann doch eine Menge Feuer, nicht nur bei uns. Da hat sich dann auch die IFF
eingeklinkt und gesagt so hör mal also so geht's ja hier überhaupt nicht und haben sich da auf jeden Fall schnell
ähm nach vorne geschoben und das hat dann wohl und das ist jetzt aus der Ferne etwas schwierig zu bewerten, inwiefern die das jetzt von Anfang an schon immer Scheiße fanden, aber aus
ähm rechtlichen Gründen meinten, erstmal diesen Weg gehen zu müssen, also so eine Techdown-Note ist, der musst du halt eigentlich erst mal gehorchen
ähm es sei denn, du bist halt entsprechend aufgestellt, dem auch sofort was entgegenzustellen und das schien bei Github offenbar nicht der Fall zu sein.
So stellen sie es zumindest in ihrem eigenen Blogpost dar, dass sie das erstmal hätten machen müssen,
Aber jetzt haben sie das halt umgedreht und waren der Meinung, na ja, ist ja überhaupt gar keine Umgehung eines Kopierschutzes. Was wollt ihr eigentlich da eure Anfrage? Ist sinnlos? Und ähm haben dementsprechend YouTube-Dell
wieder so hergestellt, wie es vorher war.
Außerdem haben sie sehr groß und breit jetzt angekündigt, dass künftig hier alles ganz anders zu machen, indem sie halt ähm.
So ein Team von Experten und Rechtsanwälten äh einbeziehen,
in künftigen Fällen, die dann halt sofort diese Behauptungen überprüfen, also sie schaffen sich quasi sozusagen System für künftige Fälle dieser Art,
und wollen, dass eben auch grundsätzlich so halten, dass hier gilt so im Zweifel für die Angeklagten, also wenn sich das sozusagen nicht eindeutig aus ihrer Perspektive eindeutig belegen lässt, dass sie dann dem erstmal,
widersprechen.
Und die ONA des äh betreffenden Codes auch mit einbeziehen, vorher kontaktieren und zu entsprechenden,
Stellungnahmen äh kommen, bevor sie halt quasi jetzt gegenüber dieser Rechtsanfrage,
reagieren, dass erstmal alle angehört werden. Also letzten Endes ein Prozess machen, ne? Und wenn dann dieser Takedown trotzdem nicht.
Vermeidbar ist aus ihrer Sicht, dann wollen sie auf jeden Fall die Gelegenheit geben, das halt kein Datenverlust rot sein, dass eben die Leute zumindest noch die Möglichkeit haben, ihre Repos komplett zu exportieren, also nicht nur den Code, den haben sie wahrscheinlich sowieso,
eben auch so diese ganzen Daten,
auf Gitarb ja letzten Endes den Wert darstellen, also Echo-Treckers und Backs, die reportet werden, et cetera, Pure Quest, Vorschläge von anderen Leuten und so weiter. Darüber hinaus wollen sie noch eine Million US-Dollar äh als Pfand auflegen,
um Developper auch selber bei diesen Klagen zu unterstützen, weil das ist ja oft das Problem, dass du eben diesen Klagen relativ hilflos gegenüber stehst, weil du einfach sagst, so, um mich hier zu wehren, müsste ich jetzt hier in Vermögen investieren, habe ich nicht,
Open Source Developer Bar, was wollt ihr eigentlich von mir? Und äh aus diesem Pfand soll dann eben entsprechend auch Geld bereitstellen,
Million Dollar klingt in der Hinsicht jetzt nicht so viel, aber das ist ja auch nichts, was man nicht später wieder aufstocken könnte, wenn man sieht, dass es wirklich gebraucht wird und was bringt. Ja,
Auf jeden Fall ähm ich lese so zwischen den Zeilen, dass die IFF sich hier mal wieder schnell verdient gemacht hat. Das ist natürlich so ein Fall, wo sie sofort drauf anspringen und äh entsprechend schnell,
ähm ihre Stärken ausspielen und es zumindest geschafft haben, Gitarb und damit natürlich auch Microsoft hier schnell mit ins Boot zu bekommen. Fast eine gute Nachricht.
Ja, ich habe so einige habe ich gesehen, die haben jetzt irgendwie Gitter meinten, das wäre aber jetzt zu spät, das Gitter da reagiert, also,
Ich muss jetzt so sagen,
wenn ich das richtig verstehe auf den DMCA Taktor und müssen sie ja mussten sie ja reagieren, haben jetzt sich überlegt, wie sie nächste Mal schneller so gut reagieren, wie sie's jetzt dann machen. Der Schaden scheint dann insgesamt ja noch
überschaubar zu sein, oder? Also, scheint doch gut scheint gut gelaufen zu sein, ist so ein bisschen mein Eindruck.
Also wenn's einen Schaden gibt, dann halt nur, was ihre eigene Reputation betrifft und das scheint sie auch schnell gemerkt zu haben und äh sind dann gleich,
auch zumindest auch sofort praktisch was gemacht und nicht nur so, ja, nee, sorry. Ja, ist ja nicht unser Problem, aber nehmen wir halt einfach zurück,
sondern eben wir verstehen oder zumindest behaupten wir in einem Blogpost jetzt erstmal, dass wir verstehen, dass es ein grundsätzliches Problem ist und wir wollen eben auch mit grundsätzlichen Maßnahmen begegnen. Das ist natürlich generell eigentlich,
grundsätzlich auch bei anderen Plattformen wünschenswert. Es ist aber schon bei Git Up noch mal ein spezielles Ding. Weil Gitarb ist eben so ein bisschen das YouTube, der Developer. Ja, ist ein bisschen schwieriger Vergleich, aber,
es ist eine eine extrem große, zentrale Community für diese für die aller Art.
Große Firmen haben dort ihre Posotories und die kleinsten Opens Horst, die wir natürlich ein paar, die ihre eigenen Server aufsetzen, aber es ist natürlich so, wenn du jetzt möchtest, dass ein,
Code auch wirklich von vielen Augen beobachtet wird. Corona-Warn-App ist auch so ein Beispiel, ja. Liegt ja auch auf GTAP rum, ja. Dann haben halt dort,
Millionen von Developern bereits einen Account wissen, wie dieses System funktioniert und sind quasi mit ihrer Beteiligung immer nur äh one click away und äh dementsprechend ist das Verbandwerden von.
Für einen Entwickler schon auch vergleichbar. Ähm zum Beispiel, wenn man seinen Account von YouTube gecancelt bekommt.
Ja, aber Tim, das geht ja nicht. Du kannst du, wenn du deinen Account von YouTube beschwert bekommst, ne, das ist ja ähm also na dann, dann da ist ja der äh Meinungsfreiheit und so in Gefahr.
Zum Beispiel bei.
Ja, also äh zwei neue, zwei neue, beachtenswerte Nachrichten von äh Deutschlands beliebtesten Vollidioten. Ähm wir haben.
KenFM,
der äh jetzt also schildert. Jetzt muss man natürlich auch so sagen, ich mein, der Mann ist in der Regel nicht dafür bekannt, dass er Fakten schildert. Insofern muss man natürlich äh jetzt auch seine Schilderung erstmal unter dem.
Hinweis nehmen, dass sie äh vorbehaltlich einer Bestätigung durch seriöse Quellen ist, aber er sagt, also sie haben ähm zwei Verwarnungen von YouTube erhalten. Das, glaube ich, ist wahr, das glaube ich gerne.
Müssen wir unseren Hörern nochmal sagen, wer das ist.
KenFM ist ein äh ist die Künstlername eines,
Verschwörungsmytikas auf der auf YouTube sich ja,
so Fragen nachgeht wie ich heute mal kurz reingeschaut. Also ihm ist aufgefallen, dass man die Professorarbeit von Christian Drosten im Internet nicht findet.
Das sind so die Themen, mit denen der sich auseinandersetzt, ja? Also ich weiß nicht, was der meint, wahrscheinlich die Habilitationsschrift, aber ähm ich mein's jetzt auch nicht so die Professorarbeit, also so,
Na ja, okay, also hat er nicht gefunden im Internet und äh mit anderen Worten, ne, Barack Obama ist kein Amerikaner.
Also muss man dazu sagen, war früher mal beim äh RBB, bei Fritz und so, hat eine Radiosendung gehabt und ist dann halt, nachdem es mit seinen ganzen
ähm antisemitischen Kommentaren und sonstigen Verschwörungs äh Themen bis hin zu äh zu wild wurde, auch da rausgeschmissen worden und seitdem schlägt er sich sozusagen als unabhängiger Journalist
äh
Genau, der ist jetzt einer der wenigen, die noch die Wahrheit sagen, ne? Alle anderen sind ja schon.
Gekauft vom System, aber er ist unabhängig und äh ja. Äh.
So, der Gates Carper Deutschland ist dann auch so dieser, geht's dann so in diese,
dass wir jetzt das Bill Gates und all uns alle chippen möchte und ja wirklich ähm allerdings muss ich jetzt auch sagen, dass ich den.
Also ich kann dem auch nicht so ewig lange zuhören, weil der halt auch sehr, sehr schnell redet und du kommst gar nicht hinterher dem jeweils noch zu sagen, so nein, hier, das ist wieder Unsinn, das ist wieder Unsinn. Ja, auf jeden Fall,
seine Schilderungen, zwei Verwarnungen von YouTube. Daraufhin hätten sie alle Videos ihres Kanals offline genommen?
Um einem einer dritten Verwarnung zu entgehen, ja? Und jetzt sagt der YouTube-Pater aber trotzdem,
gestern den Kanal gelöscht. Es gibt aber jetzt irgendwie auch andere Leute, die sagen, dass der Kanal sei nicht gelöscht, der wäre nur auf privat geschaltet.
Kann das nicht so ganz beurteilen. Ähm wenn ich denke, ehrlich gesagt, wenn der von seinem Kanal alle Videos offline genommen hat,
dann hätte YouTube eigentlich keinen Anlass gehabt, den noch zu löschen. Ähm diese Ankündigung, sie seien gelöscht worden, geht aber einher mit der Bewerbung,
vieler äh eigener äh Apps und eines Telegramkanals. Insofern ja könnte das jetzt auch eine.
Eine Maßnahme sein dieses Geschäftsmodell halt irgendwie auf eine andere Ebene zu heben, ja? Also zumal ist ja auch irgendwie regelmäßig von YouTube Bestrebungen gibt,
mit solchen ähm ja eben durch Desinformation auffallenden Kanälen ähm dafür zu sorgen, dass die weniger Einnahmen haben.
Und äh.
Dass das dann eventuell auch ein finanziell motivierter Schritt ist. Ansonsten weitere gute Nachricht von KenFM, er möchte also jetzt Berlin verlassen,
ich persönlich jetzt als äh keine schlechte Nachricht empfinde, will irgendwo in Brandenburg aufm Land eine Corona-Begegnungsstätte machen,
und das äh finde ich ganz gut. Ja, finde ich in Ordnung. Hm, ich.
Gott.
Tut mir ein bisschen äh ich ich bin ja eigentlich schon ein Verfechter der Idee, dass halt,
jede jede Person in die Welt setzen, ihre Meinungen in die Welt setzen soll, aber das ist eben wenn man sich diesen Jepsen anhört, der kennt eben nicht den Unterschied zwischen Meinungen und Fakten, ja und,
kann denen also vertritt den eben so auch nicht. Der surft da die ganze Zeit. Also mit irgendwelchen.
Stellt im Prinzip am laufenden Band falsche Tatsachenbehauptungen auf,
und deklariert die dann als Meinung und finde empfindet seine Meinung dann als beschnitten weil weil die Realität eben seine Fakten nicht wieder gibt und das ist,
Also ich denke, das Problem ist tatsächlich eher YouTube als Ken Jepsen, weil solche ähm Leute hatten wir schon immer.
Und ähm ja.
Passiert eben auch nur alle sechzig, siebzig Jahre, dass die nennenswerte Menschen mobilisieren, ne.
Gut, es packt nur so ein bisschen den Eindruck, ich meine, wir hatten das jetzt vor ein paar Wochen schon in den USA mit äh und so, das äh also hier so eine takedown Welle durch YouTube geschwappt ist und auch äh bei Twitter ist ja einiges äh unternommen worden bei Facebook
angeblich ja auch ein bisschen was, aber sicherlich nicht im ausreichenden Maße.
Und äh jetzt habe ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass äh das Ganze jetzt auch auf nachdem die Wahl durch ist,
Sie sich jetzt sozusagen auch um den Rest äh der Welt. Ich finde das ja grundsätzlich löblich, wenn's natürlich auch, wie wir hier auch schon mehrfach diskutiert haben,
schwierig ist, ne. Wir erleben natürlich mittlerweile einfach eine Privatisierung der Öffentlichkeit. Es ist gibt halt nicht Öffentlichkeit ist nicht mehr so sehr definiert durch.
Einen öffentlichen Rundfunk, der es halt lange, lange Zeit war, weil ähm
natürlich zu Beginn sich das sowieso niemand so äh hätte leisten können. Schon in Deutschland haben wir das ganz gut beobachten können, nachdem dann in den Achtzigern und vor allem auch in den neunziger Jahren private Fernsehradiokanäle aufgemacht haben, das,
es schwieriger wird, dieses.
Meinung mehr irgendwie mit allgemein akzeptierten Regeln in den Griff zu bekommen. Und durchs Internet ist das Ganze halt jetzt nochmal hoch fünf unterwegs,
und wir haben ja jetzt äh mehrfach schon diskutiert und auch alle,
gesehen, wie sehr das dann äh auch schnell aus dem Ruder laufen kann, weil das ist dann ja irgendwie dann nicht mehr eine Diskussion um schlechten Journalismus, sondern hier kann im Prinzip jeder Hanswurst mit einer bekloppten Idee und jeder äh,
einfach auf ähm derselben Augenhöhe,
sein Gift in die Welt streuen und das ist ein Problem. So, das ist halt einfach ein Problem. Und man kann natürlich jetzt ganz allgemein sagen, na ja, Meinungsfreiheit ist ein hohes Gut, würde ich ja da auch durchaus zustimmen. Nur ähm,
ist halt jetzt an dieser Stelle wahrscheinlich auch einfach eine Zivilcourage gefragt.
Und das ist wohl das, was YouTube hier versucht, wahrzunehmen.
Ja
Natürlich schwierig ist, ne, weil was ist, wenn diese Zivilcourage irgendwann mal in eine andere Richtung,
umschlägt und weil irgendein Unternehmen der Meinung ist, das wäre für sie eigentlich sehr viel praktischer, wenn sie jetzt hier irgendwie den Holzköpfen freien Lauf bringt und dann
legitime unabhängige journalistische Berichterstattung querlegt
das, das ist natürlich das, was wir immer im Hinterkopf haben und auch immer an dieser Debatte schon immer so
schwierig gefunden haben und auch nach wie vor schwierig äh finden. Nichtsdestotrotz gehe ich jetzt mit diesen,
als solchen, die jetzt hier von uns berichtet wurden, erstmal konform.
Also ich find's halt schwierig, vor allem, weil ich unabhängig davon.
Dass ich sage, also ne, dass also das Ziel sollte sein, dass solche ähm wirren Menschen möglichst keine Aufmerksamkeit
keit von anderen bekommen, weil ihnen diese Aufmerksamkeit ja auch nicht gut tut, wie wir bei dem zweiten Fall gleich noch besprechen werden. Ähm ich stelle aber auch fest, dass
da wird man hat natürlich die Sorge, dass.
Da jetzt, die sich ihren ihren Opfermythos schaffen, ne, von der geplagten von ihrer geplagten deutschen Seele und ähm dann diese leider ähm.
Existierenden Tendenzen, also äh sorry, ja, also die Situation ist ja so, die nehmen.
Einfach grundsätzlich die Realität als ihre Gegnerin war und leugnen sie, ja? Und sie glauben,
auch einfach gar nichts mehr, was in der Zeitung steht oder äh von den von seriösen Medien berichtet wird oder von seriösen Politikerinnen gesagt wird, weil sie einfach zu oft die Erfahrung gemacht haben, dass das,
nicht stimmt. Ne, also man könnte im Prinzip sagen, die Sachen stimmen allein schon deshalb nicht, weil sie in der Zeitung stehen, ja? Das reicht denen dann schon aus.
Und das ist nicht so, als kämen die aus dem Nichts, ne? Die Leute wurden ja äh in diesem Land,
von unterschiedlichen Medien und unterschiedlichen politischen äh Größen auch wirklich über Jahrzehnte relativ übel verarscht. Ähm,
Das darf man sicher nicht, ähm darf man ja nicht vergessen, dass sich, ja, dass,
die Eliten auch ein bisschen selbstverschuldet in diese Position gebracht haben, dass ihnen inzwischen einfach niemand mehr glauben möchte und die Leute sagen, hier in dieser.
In dieser Welt habe ich nichts mehr zu verlieren. Ähm also glaube ich jetzt eben den den wirren Quatsch, den.
Hier irgendjemand redet. Ähm meine Sorge ist, wenn du schon an dem Punkt bist,
entstehen natürlich dadurch, dass du jetzt mal von den Wasserwerfer ein bisschen beregnet wirst auf Stufe eins oder dass dir der YouTube Account gelöscht wird, weil du ohne Ende äh Scheiße geredet hast. Ähm dass die.
Sich dadurch halt irgendwie so einen Gründungsmythos schaffen, wo sie sich dann vollends von der Welt und der Realität verabschieden, ne. Und du hast ja,
bei Leuten, die jetzt irgendwie diesen Einlassungen oder hier von dem
Avocado äh da irgendwie die den den Einlassung folgen, dass die sich ja quasi konkret,
widersetzen andere Informationen zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Ja und daher könnte natürlich,
auch langfristig oder mittelfristig schon ein Weckzug von YouTube insofern Problem sein, dass sie dann das,
dass ihre Follower dann auf irgendwelchen Videoplattformen Videos gucken, wo noch nicht mal mehr ähm von anderen Leuten ähm eine Stimme der Vernunft dem gegenüber gesetzt,
und deswegen stehe ich solchen Ideen sehr ähm,
Gegenüber. Ein Argument, was man dafür sehen könnte, wäre natürlich, na ja, wenn du Glück hast, verdient er dadurch weniger Geld, wenn er weniger Geld hat, kann er weniger Unsinn produzieren, weniger Unsinn produziert
äh gucken sich den Unsinn weniger Leute an und äh dann den Rest regelt der Markt, ne? Das könnte man natürlich auch äh sich so vorstellen. Aber ich habe.
Ehrlich gesagt kein gutes Gefühl dabei, wenn ich das sehe. Äh ich habe das auch schon nicht gehabt bei Alex Jones als der von YouTube äh geflogen ist.
Und ich denke, dass mit den Schwulen Fröschen sollte auf jeden Fall nochmal untersucht werden so. Und ansonsten noch ein weiteres schönes Video. Hm.
Gibt's ein Interview eines und wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, ist der Interviewer selber da auch eher so aus diesem rechtsradikalen Umfeld.
Und der interviewed den ehemaligen Leibwächter.
Von hier von Avocado erfüllt man oder wie ich auch letztens hörte, vom Hiersedler,
der äh und schildert, äh interessant ist. Ähm über eben.
Attila Hildmann, zusammengefasst, ähm dass er.
Aufgrund seiner Initialen sind das für ein Zeichen hält, dass er in Wirklichkeit Adolf Hitler sei und dass die Welt jetzt irgendwie gerettet wird von ihm, vor der Merkel-Diktatur, dass er außerdem äh Schwierigkeiten,
einzuschlafen und sich irgendwie in der Nacht fürchtet, weshalb er eben diesen Leibwächter unter anderem auch hatte,
und dass er äh eben des nachts, wenn er nicht schlafen kann, weint,
Und tatsächlich all das passt in der Störungsbild was dieser Mann relativ offensichtlich zeigt wenn man sich dessen Telegram Kanal da mal zu Gemüte führt. Dieser Mann hat.
Ernsthafte Anzeichen einer Psychose. Und ähm.
Das schildert dieser ähm dieser Leibwächter ähm da sehr schön. Der Leibwächter sieht jetzt auch nicht aus, wen links grün,
versiffter Kommunist. Ja, muss man dann ganz ehrlich sagen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich ähm wie ich den jetzt politisch einschätzen würde.
Aber na ja, ist halt ein Leibwächter und äh der erzählt da, macht er halt mal reinen Tisch und sagt, dass er den Eindruck hat, dass der Typ am Rad dreht. Und ähm wenn das sogar der schon merkt, dann besteht ja vielleicht auch Hoffnung.
Ja, drei Tage hat er's ausgehalten bei ihm. Der Pömp, beim Avocado.
Ich finde das schon es ist, es ist es ist so dramatisch, dass die Leute, ne, du hast eine Pandemie.
Und die Leute, die Leute dichten sich echt zusammen, dieses Virus, mit dem gerade hier, ne, die Krankenhäuser voll sind.
In anderen Leuten schon wieder nah haarscharf daran sind, Triage einzuführen. Das ist ungefährlich,
Vor nichts haben die mehr Angst als vor einem Impfstoff. Ich finde das so das ist schon ein bisschen zum Heulen. Ich kann mir das auch nur noch hier ich habe eine Zeit lang habe ich mir da echt diesen,
Telegram-Kanal angeschaut.
Ich kann das auch nicht mehr. Das ist wirklich äh belastend so, dir das anzugucken, weil ich also auch aus Mitleid. Welche mit weil ich mir die ganze Zeit da so wie wie der Lauterbach sitze und den armen Ruder und mir vor die Stirn schlage, so.
Nein.
Ja. Ne, vor allem, wenn du dann auch Leute kennst, die die dann auch noch in diesen Sumpf mit reingezogen werden, dann wird's halt richtig unangenehm.
Aber um nochmal zu diesem Ken Jepsen zu kommen, ich denke, ehrlich gesagt, ein Umgang mit, also,
Was twit, was twitter jetzt macht mit, wenn wenn Donald Trump Unsinn redet. Ja, und einfach quasi einen Hinweis hinmachen, so dass äh ist nicht
äh ist ist durch Tatsachen nicht gedeckt. Ja, weil sie da ja noch sehr moderat sind, ne, immer nur sagen so Disclaime ist disputet, also umstritten, diese Behauptung ist umstritten, statt einfach mal zu sagen,
Unsinn, Quatsch, Quatsch! Ähm ich glaube, dass vielleicht der Weg von YouTube sein,
könnte ähm so etwas in dieser Art äh zu machen.
Also ich denke, da wir ja nicht so genau wissen, was jetzt da wirklich passiert ist, ist gesperrt, äh deaktiviert.
Oder oder wurde nur gezwungen, äh alles runterzunehmen. Es kann halt auch einfach gut sein, dass hier äh die Demonitarisierung gedroht hat.
Sagen wir mal an der Stelle auch ein legitimes Mittel ist. Und.
Ist halt auch so, dass ich einfach auch viele, die da ähm Auguren, dieser skurrilen Szene.
Finden auch einfach gar keinen anderen Job mehr.
Ich meine, die sind einfach mal so dermaßen isoliert, wenn der Kenn FM jetzt sogar schon Berlin verlassen muss, weil er meint, er findet hier gar keine Räume, wo er Leute interviewen kann.
Der kriegt nichts gemietet, ne? Der ist einfach raus aus dem äh Spiel. So und aber er lebt ja davon. Das ist ja das das bringt ihm ja Geld.
Und sicherlich auch nicht wenig. Und äh in dem Moment, wo dann halt einfach YouTube sagt, na ja, dann wird das jetzt ja hier mal demonitarisiert, weil den Unsinn, den können wir hier nicht auch noch finanziell äh bezuschussen aus unseren Werbeeinnahmen
Na ja, dann äh zeigt sich halt dann auch schnell, äh was der eigentliche Zweck,
Klar, diese Verstörung ist sicherlich real, ne? Aber am Ende äh kämpfen die auch dann alle um ihre Existenz. Da ist natürlich dann diese Abdringung in diese
Was weiß ich, braunen YouTubes, die sich dann vielleicht später irgendwann mal äh gründen, wie du ja auch schon,
durchaus zu Recht auch mit befürchtet hast. Das sind dann nicht unbedingt jetzt so die Umsatzmaschinen dann, ne. Kann sich natürlich auch ändern und man könnte auch sagen, wenn man sich das in den USA anschaut, so Fox-News ist, letzten Endes ja auch nichts anderes
Wissen wir nicht, wie's äh läuft.
Aber jetzt ist er auf jeden Fall erstmal raus aus Berlin und raus aus YouTube und äh nur noch über Telegram zu empfangen.
Ja, also nee, nee, die die Videos kannst du dir auf der einen Webseite dann anschauen, ne? Also.
Tja, wenn du einen Server bezahlen kann.
Also ehrlich gesagt glaube ich sehr wohl, dass der gute Herr äh oder wie man seinen äh richtigen Namen ausspricht. Ähm
in der Lage ist, einen Server zu
treiben, ne? Der hat ja auch äh also das ist, ich glaube nicht, dass der irgendwie mit äh tausend Euro im Monat irgendwo zu Hause und einer Webcam sitzt so. Der hat sich da schon über viele Jahre da aufgebaut, dass das äh ein
erträgliches äh Mediending ist, was er da betreibt, ne.
Drei Kinder auch mit großziehen Leut Wikipedia. Na ja gut ähm.
Also ich bleibe dabei, ein gutes Gefühl habe ich dabei nicht
Wenn so jemand gelöscht wird, ich habe allerdings auch kein besonders gutes Gefühl dabei, wenn so ein Spinner äh so viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommt. Und deswegen denke ich, das Problem liegt
irgendwo anders dran. Also daran, wie an den viel von uns diskutierten YouTube, Algorithmen, auch daran, dass
die,
die Politik kehren und Politiker, die er da kritisiert, tatsächlich ja auch viel getan haben, um das Vertrauen zu verspielen.
Und ähm insofern ist das alles ein äh ist der ist der Typ auch nur ein ein Symptom, ne? Keine Ursache.
Du bist doch so dumm, ey.
Handy. So und dann haben wir.
Gib Handy, du Symptom.
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar schon eine eine LMP Sendung, die heißt.
Ja, ja. Da war was.
Wir haben das schon vor längerer Zeit mal drüber gesprochen, ja. Okay, damit sind wir am Ende äh der Fahnenstange ähm angelangt.
Nächste Woche gibt's neue Sachen, die wir schon immer sowieso gesagt haben.
Und dann wird die Seele der Deutschen weitergeplagt.
Genau. Du wirst wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Dankes äh Hymnen.
Ich würde ein bisschen danken und zwar äh danke ich besonders Karsten und besonders Nils und Daniela und Jani und Peter und Michael, Steffen, Benjamin Jannick
und Ralf und Astrid und Johannes und Christian und Marko und Jens und Sascha und Jonas,
und M Punkt.
Immer ominöser.
Das ist also euch gilt auf jeden Fall mein ähm herzlicher Dank, abonniert bitte meinen Telegram-Kanal, denn nur da, nur da gibt's die Wahrheit.
Ich äh möchte mich bedanken bei allen, die schon dem Aufruf gefolgt sind und ihre Daueraufträge auf das neue Konto umgestellt haben. Das äh hat schon bei sehr vielen geklappt. So wie es aussieht, das wird sich natürlich erst im Laufe eines Monats vollständig zeigen, denke ich.
Falls ihr nicht wisst, wovon ich rede,
Vorletzte Sendung habe ich's glaube ich ausführlicher dargelegt. Ich packe auch nochmal den Link rein. Ähm wer einen Dauerauftrag hat, sollte bitte das Konto ändern.
Dauerauftrag an Tim hat, sollte das Konto.
Wer ein Dauerauftrag an die Mieterebene äh hat, die auch dieses Programm.
Genau.
Nee, wenn ihr einen Dauerauftrag bei Linos habt, könnt ihr das auch auf die Meter eben aufs neue Konto ändern. Kein Problem.
Muss ja rumkommen hier.
Oje. Okay.
Ja. Wie soll ich denn meine Verschwörungstheorie weiter finanzieren sonst.
Linus FM, der Britner, die fandet nicht.
Sonst muss ich ins Darknet abwandern.
Oje. Okay.
Tschüss, Leute. Bis bald.
Bis bald, tschau, tschau.